[Music]
exoplanets more than anything else in
the universe are really places
we know and love the planets in our
solar system and i think it's such a
beautiful thing to be able to explore
these other worlds around distant stars
exoplanet science has really exploded
over the last 25 years we went from not
knowing of any planets outside the solar
system to now knowing over four thousand
[Music]
almost every star has at least one
planet
and there are a lot of planets out there
that may not be so different from our
own earth
most of them are very very nearby so in
the scheme of things in the big picture
of the galaxy they're right next door
for me the biggest question is where
does earth fit in in the universe are we
special are there a lot of other planets
like earth or not and in my work i study
the atmospheres of exoplanets so i'm
interested in what kinds of chemicals
are in the atmosphere what their
climates are like their weather
we see a lot of pretty pictures from
other types of astronomy but for
exoplanets we usually don't see them so
we find evidence for them like if a star
gets a little bit fainter that could be
from a planet passing in front
we can detect that drop in brightness
and use that to tell us what size the
planet is at different wavelengths and
that tells us what the atmosphere is
made out of
you have to be very imaginative to take
the things that we can measure and turn
that into information about the planets
exoplanets are
always surprising i think we have a
pretty limited imagination based on the
planets of our solar system and so every
time we look at an exoplanet we see
something that is unexpected
my most surprising discovery was very
unusual clouds on a mini neptune planet
they're probably clouds that are made
out of minerals like potassium chloride
or zinc sulfide so totally different
from anything in the solar system
i think it's safe to say that we're
really in a golden age of astronomy
right now and a lot of that is driven by
technology so we're building telescopes
that are bigger and more sensitive than
ever before particularly in space for
the type of work that i do studying the
atmospheres of other planets it's a lot
easier to do this when earth's own
atmosphere is not in the way
[Music]
[Music]
i feel so incredibly lucky that i get to
use this telescope because it was really
it was first talked about in the 1990s
when i was just a kid it's been many
many many years in the making it's the
successor to hubble so it'll be in space
james webb is really a dream come true
for exoplanet science as much as i love
hubble which i've used for my work a lot
james webb will take us many steps
forward it will have observing
capability that we've never had before
in all of human history
it will allow us to answer questions
that are really important for
understanding what our place in the
universe is
we know that rocky planets are common
all over the galaxy but what are they
like are they nice environments for life
to evolve on or not james webb will make
huge progress in answering those
questions
[Music]
the way that i approach looking for an
inhabited planet is to study what its
atmosphere is made out of
if you looked at the earth from far away
you would see oxygen and methane in our
own atmosphere and from a chemistry
standpoint that is really strange
because normally those two molecules
will react with each other to form
something else
and so that's the smoking gun evidence
on the earth that something
is producing both oxygen and methane and
our best explanation for what that is is
life
i am an optimist i definitely think
there's alien life out there
we know that there are tens of billions
of rocky planets in our galaxy alone
many of them may have water
the universe is old so if you wait
around long enough if you have all the
ingredients that you need to make life i
think it's only a matter of time
before it happens
as a scientist i try to be
rational and objective about things but
it's such an emotional
topic
if i imagine myself being the first
person to find evidence for life on
another planet i'd probably be in tears
i mean i think to know something so big
that we're not alone would be an
incredible feeling
[Music]
[Music]
you